In this video I'm going to show you how to do the MinMaxScaler example that we
just did by hand but now in sklearn.
So the MinMaxScaler, as always, is something that I
first find out about by visiting the sklearn documentation using Google.
So when I google for an example I get something like this.
And I click on the first link.
There's a number of different functions that Python has available to you for
preprocessing data.
We'll be looking at the MinMaxScaler today, and
that falls under this paragraph of scaling features to a range.
This is the documentation page that I had open when I came up
with the example that I'm going to show you right now,
so in order to make it maximally easy to follow, I
would suggest that you sort of have this open in a parallel tab in your browser.
But I'll also be explaining each step as I go through it,
to show you how to use this in a practical example.
I come over in my Terminal window and I fire up the Python interpreter.
And the first thing that I am going to need to do is import the module.
The next thing that I actually need to do,
this is one of the things that was tricky for me the first time around.
Is import numpy, because as you might have sort of noticed by now,
a lot of the sklearn functions require numpy inputs.
So let me show you what I mean.
I'm going to be using weights data in this example, so
I'm going to create a feature called weights, and
as it happens I'm going to make this into a numpy array.
I just got this from the example on the sklearn documentation page
that I showed you.
This is kind of me following the steps that they laid out.
What I do now is I make my input data.
So in this case, I'll be using the weights example.
And something that's a little bit tricky that I had to
play around with to figure out, is that what you actually want is a numpy array.
Each element of the numpy array is going be a different training point, and
then each element within that training point is going to be a feature.
So in this case I'm really only interested in one feature, the weights feature,
and then I have three different training points for my three different people.
So when I put in my data, it looks like this.
Now that I have my weights data input I'm ready to use the scaler on that.
Here's the scaler that I imported from sklearn.preprocessing.
And I want to have a new feature that's named rescaled,
let's call it rescaled_weight.
And to make rescaled_weight, what I do is call fit_transform on the weights.
So this actually does two things.
The first thing that it does is it fits.
So it does things like find the x_min and the x_max, and then the transform
actually applies the formula to all the elements in the, in the set of data.
So this is doing two things at the same time.
Sometimes you'll only want to do one or the other.
Now, I've actually set myself up to make a mistake here.
Let me show you what happens.
All right. So we got an error here that says its going,
it's assuming floating point values as, as input, but instead it got integers.
And the reason why has to do with this line right here.
All these inputs are integers, but it's expecting floating point numbers, and
if you were looking at the documentation, the example,
very closely as I was doing this, you might have
figured out that this was going to be a problem down the road for us.
So, I am going to turn these into floating point numbers by putting
a decimal point after each one of them and we'll try this again.
Great. That looks much better.
Let me print it out now.
And there is our new transformed feature.
So, there is the 0.417 that we calculated in the last example.
You can also see that the smallest value in a list has a rescale value of zero,
and the largest one has a rescale value of one.
Which, if you look at the equation carefully,
will immediately become apparent that that's always going to be true.
So this is an example of how you can use the MinMaxScaler in sklearn to
do in just a couple lines what we did by hand in the last example.